[Music]
at the nine causes a depression and
anxiety I learned about one that lost
connections there were a few that were
really challenging for me because I
realized how much I recognized them in
myself so one of the hardest I have to
tell you was talking about something
else first but when I was in 2009 on
Christmas Eve it makes it even sadder
that a story hopeful of Christmas Eve so
I used to live on junk feelings to eat
appallingly
and on Christmas Eve 2009 I went to my
local KFC at lunchtime and I turned up
and I gave my order which is so
disgusting I would even repeat it and
the guy behind the counter said Oh
Johann I'm so glad you're here wait a
minute I was like okay so he walked off
and he came back with all the other
staff and they bought me a massive
Christmas card and they'd written in it
to our best customer and as I was
looking at this in my clogged heart sank
I thought this isn't even the fried
chicken shop I come to the most it was a
very unfortunate low point but we all
know right junk food has taken over our
diets not admittedly to the extreme that
I was but junk food is increasingly
dominating our diets and it's making us
physically sick one things that really
shot me in the research is that there's
there's there's really good evidence
there's something similar has happened
with our minds that are kind of junk
values have taken over our minds and
they've made us mentally sick so but for
thousands of years now philosophers have
said if you think life is about you know
money and status and and showing off
you're gonna feel terrible right from
Confucius on down people at rewarding as
that but weirdly nobody had actually
scientifically investigated it until an
incredible man I got to know call
Professor Tim Kassar who's at Knox
University in Illinois so professor
kasih knew when it comes to human
motivation there's basically to put it
crudely two kinds of human motivation
right imagine you play the piano if you
play the piano in the morning because
you love it and it gives you joy that's
an intrinsic motivation you're not doing
it to get something out of it
you're just doing it because that thing
gives you joy right okay now imagine you
play the piano not because it gives you
joy but in a dive bar to pay the rent
or because your parents are really
pressuring you to
be a piano maestro or I'd know to
impress a man maybe some weird piano
fetishist right that would be an
extrinsic reason to play the piano
you're not doing it for the experience
itself you're doing it to get something
out you're doing it a one remove you're
doing it to get something out of the
experience now we're all a mixture of
intrinsic and extrinsic values obviously
and we change throughout our lives but
professor kasih discovered some really
fascinating things the first thing is
the more your life is dominated by
extrinsic values the more you're doing
things not because you think they're
important but because of how you look to
other people how you'll seem on the
outside the more likely you are to
become depressed and anxious it's a
quite a significant effect it's been
found in 22 studies with depression and
14 studies with anxiety now there are
many reasons I'll give you just one one
of the things we know is that something
that's a real source of joy in human
life so it's really necessary or what
are called flow states right they're
moments when you're doing something you
really love for me it's writing for
someone else it might be running it's
definitely all that for me or you know
whatever when you time seems to collapse
you're totally in the moment of what
you're doing and you're just you're
flowing right but extreme extrinsic
values massively disrupt your ability to
get into flow States if you imagine as
you're playing the piano imagine the
guys playing the piano for intrinsic
reasons right because it gives him joy
now imagine suddenly he has to think am
I the best piano player in New York City
today who's better than me how are these
people listening to me how are they
judging am I going to get paid for this
you can see how it would jolt you out of
the flow state right when you think
extrinsic when you get jolted out of
flow State there are many reasons why
extrinsic values make us feel bad and
they ruin the quality of your
relationships they've crowd out
intrinsic values there's all sorts of
things going on but press Cass was also
showing that extrinsic values have been
taking over our culture we are becoming
more and more dominated by these
extrinsic values this is we are immersed
in this way of thinking from the moment
we're born more eighteen-month-old
children recognize the MacDonalds m than
know their own surname we are pickled in
advertising messages telling us that
life is about living extrinsically right
imagine an advert that told you you know
what you're great you look fine you
smell nice you're amazing you don't need
anything more today
that would be the worst advert that ever
been done right advertising is the
ultimate frenemy it's always telling you
oh babe I love you it's just you know
only you didn't stink right that now
what professor casa showed is he puts it
is at some level we all know this right
everyone watching this knows you're not
going to lie on the on the last day of
your life you will not lie there and
think about all the things you bought
right you will not think about you know
all the hours you put in at the office
you will think about moments of deep
meaning and connection but as Professor
Casa puts it we live in a machine that
is constantly diverting us from what is
meaningful about life there's a you know
a wonderful experiment was done before
professor castles work but I think it
really illustrates this and it was done
in 1978 it's really simple experiment
you get a lot of five-year-olds and you
put them in a sandpit and you split them
into two groups the first group is shown
to advertisements for a specific toy
whatever the 1978 equivalent of Peppa
Pig was right and the second group is
shown no show no adverts and at the end
of it they give all the kids a choice
they said okay kids got a choice now you
could either play with a nice boy who
doesn't have the toy for in the advert
or you can play with a nasty boy who's
got the toy the kids who didn't see the
ad mostly choose the nice boy without
the toy and the kids who saw the ad
mostly choose the nasty boy who's got
the toy so just two advertisements two
primed those children to choose an
inanimate lump of plastic over kindness
and connection we are all being driven
by way more advertising than that every
day right anyone watching this and I
would include myself in that who's
stayed late at work do something they
don't want to do to buy something they
don't need rather than go be home with
their kids maybe you've fallen prey to
that dynamic and professor caso has
really shown this way that we've got to
we've got to unpick these junk values
these junk values what we've been fed
for so long they're a kind of KFC for
the Soul and they're making us feel
terrible
[Music]